faces hidden location concealed only
then with these Hong Kong entrepreneurs
agree to be filmed they've set up an
online shopping service which supports
the pro-democracy movement it employs
protesters who've been arrested or
kicked out of their homes for their part
in the demonstrations we want to provide
for the teenagers and everyone that is
involved in this movement they should be
proud of what they are doing we are
proud of them and we will support them
with their career despite being a world
away from the frontlines initiatives
like this work in fear the founders all
volunteers say being identified could
jeopardize their careers perhaps even
their safety bars with a newborn son
logistics manager Caleb says getting
caught up in violent protests isn't an
option
personally I don't have the courage to
go on the frontlines and fight with them
so I fell into this backup role and
started this company and let them know
that they are not left behind and the
Hong Kong people are supporting them
with this scheme Caleb's among the
growing ranks of Hong Kong is finding
inventive ways to support the
pro-democracy cause when you picture the
Hong Kong protests warehouses like this
one won't be the first thing that
springs to mind but far from the
frontlines it's behind the scenes
initiatives like this one that are
quietly and collectively sustaining this
movement Caleb says he hopes one day he
and his team won't have to hide their
identities and will feel safe to proudly
admit the role they've played we have
glaciar Quang joining us in the studio
she's a member of the Hong Kong activist
group keyboard a front line so glaciar
with that video report we just saw you
have these volunteers not on the front
lines because they feel like they can't
necessarily participate in the protests
all the time is there still a danger to
the work they're doing yes of course
there are dangerous for them as not
being very involved in the front line as
well because if they were found out or
their identities being revealed they
will get themselves into trouble I have
friends who do similar work in Hong Kong
and he was target
his personal particulars are being put
online and his shot was being harassed
and people are saying that they were
blocking him and really gave him a hard
time so so somebody you know got doxxed
essentially yeah because of the work
that he's trying to do on his shop to
support the movement so if you're saying
you're gonna hire people from their
front line then you actually exposing
yourself to two troubles in that sense I
think it's very interesting that you
have people of different ages
contributing in different ways and
people with different skills whether
some of the musicians performing music
each person has a role tell me about
your role and your organization my role
because I'm now basing it based in
Germany so I do a bit of lobbying trying
to get the narrative about the Hong Kong
movement out there - for the others and
my group actually focuses on technology
and Internet related things so we try to
give advice to the activist on how do
you encrypt your device how do you keep
your information safe in terms of a
digital sense and we are also trying to
formulate a report talking about the
surveillance the time of China and Hong
Kong China and even the world do you
think activists are improving in terms
of their digital hygiene and protecting
themselves yes of course we see a
improving trend in general when compared
like five years ago Lin the umbrella
revolution people don't really know if
they need to use end-to-end encryption
and they can't talk about sensitive
things openly online but now we see that
people are more aware of ok certain
things we cannot say in the open area on
the internet but we can do it via
end-to-end encryption and sometimes
people will come to ask and how do I
kill my information safe so see we see
an increase of awareness in this sense
now I want to step back a little bit and
talk about short term versus long term
short term Beijing strategy or rather
the Hong Kong police forces strategy is
to lob as much tear gas as possible it
doesn't seem to be working based on the
turnout this weekend for example but
long term Beijing has said that it wants
to increase and roll out patriotic
education in the school system and to
also decrease teaching of critical
thinking skills in classrooms do you
think they will prevail that the next
generation is going to be more
nationalistic I think actually it won't
because we can see from the past
experience in 2012 the government tried
to launch the national national
education in Hong Kong and they failed
but then they separated the whole
curriculum and the implemented part by
part in Hong Kong but still the whole
generation of youngsters actually very
against the rule of the Chinese regime
so we can see that doesn't work and I
think as long as we keep talking about
these kind of so core critical thinking
a criticism about the Hong Kong the
Chinese government I don't think they
would succeed in terms of brainwashing
the next generation because we have one
solid generation that is so against the
rule of China and Hong Kong government
in that sense and I think this is the
question that everybody must ask you all
the time but how do you think this is
all going to end I have no idea to be
honest I don't see the Hong Kong regime
or the Chinese regime gonna fall and
like a tip of the finger but I think in
the long term dictatorship will
eventually fall and we're counting on
that so even though we don't see any
actual hope of succeeding at this moment
we know we're doing the right thing
we're gonna continue glaciar Kwang thank
you